foreign
Adventure
The Last of Us takes place 20 years
after a very specific outbreak happened
that involves fungus that fungus is real
if it were to be able to infect humans
it would go like that it's terrifying
viruses can make us ill but fungi can
alter our very Minds
no
Joel is a broken man he's a father who
has experienced loss I don't save
Sarah's life which is Joel's daughter
which is the event that shapes the
character for the rest of his life
a black market Smuggler who's tasked
with a job of transporting this 14 year
old girl named Ellie to this military
group that provides hope for mankind to
develop a vaccine
when you're adapting something like a
video game changes have to be done
smartly we are telling more there is so
much in between can I have a gun no I'm
not I was advised not to play the game
but I just watched him the game play
there secretly
is going to be beautiful terrifying But
ultimately it's enlightening
how good does it justice and then some